[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم تاجلت جلسه كان مقررا عقدها
بين مبعوث الامم المتحده جمال بن عمر
واحزاب اللقاء المشترك وجماعه الحوثي بعد
انسحاب التنظيم الوحدويه الناصر والحزب
الاشتراكي احتجاجا على ممارسات العنف من
قبل جماعه انصار الله اما الناطق باسم حزب
الاصلاح فقال ان الحزب يرفض الحوار مع
جماعه الحوثي نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش
في
محورين الى اين يمكن ان تصل حركه الاحتجاج
ضد سيطره الحوثيين على
اليمن وهل يمكن ان يتدخل المجتمع الدولي
ويعيد الامور الى نصابها في البلاد
اليمن في وضع دستوري وسياسي شائك بعد
اربعه ايام على استقاله الرئيس عبد ربو
منصور هادي ورئيس الحكومه خالد بحاح ومع
اقتراب الذكرى الرابعه لثوره الحادي عشر
من فبراير يبدو شباب الثوره الذين اعتصموا
في الميادين مده طويله حتى خلع نظام علي
عبد الله صالح يبدو انهم في طريق استعاده
ثورتهم ولكن هذه المره ضد
حثين اربعه ايام بلا دوله و 18 يوما قبل
ذكرى الثوره مفارقه قد تصلح مدخلا لقراءه
المشهد اليمني الذي لم يكن اقرب للتشظي
الكامل كما هو الان توفر سيطره الحوثيين
على مفاصل الدوله بقوه السلاح زخما لحراك
الثوار قبل ايام من حلول الذكرى الرابعه
لانطلاق ثوره الحادي عشر من فبراير التي
كانت تصبو لبناء يمن حر ديمقراطي موحد
شباب الثوره الذين استفاقوا على قطع
الطريق على الانتقال الديمقراطي المتعثر
بالاساس قرروا العوده الى الميادين رفضا
لواقع يرونه مجهض لاحلام لكن الحوثيين
الذين يعتبرون اجتياحهم المسلحه لعموم
المحافظات اليمنيه فعلا ثوريا تنجزه
لجانهم الشعبيه يبدو انهم ضاقوا سريعا
بالحراك السلمي فرقت جماعه الحوثي مظاهره
طلابيه امام جامعه صنعاء ونفذ عناصرها
حمله اعتقالات واسعه بحق طلاب ونشطاء كما
لاحقوا متظاهرين في شوارع قريبه من ساحه
التغيير بالعاصمه كان حظ الطلاب والطالبات
الضرب باعقاب البنادق الحوثيه كما جرت
محاولات دهس بالسيارات اسفرت عن اصابات
خفيفه لبعض
المتظاهرين تصعيد يلقي ظلال غموض على
المشهد السياسي وخاصه مع ارجاء جلسه لمجلس
النواب كانت مقرره صباح الاحد للبث في
استقاله الرئيس عبد ربو منصور هادي
والحكومه يتساءل مراقبون عمن ينتظر راي
البرلمان في تقرير مصير رئيس واقع تحت
الاقامه الجبريه قوا كثيره منها الحوثيون
ترفض شرعيه البرلمان من الاساس لكن هناك
من يرى ان فريق الرئيس المخلوع علي عبد
الله صالح هو فقط من يرى في هذا المجلس
امتدادا لنظامه ليس الجنوب احسن حالا
مصادر امنيه افادت بسقوط قتيلين على الاقل
احدهما جندي فيما اصيب اخرون في اشتباكات
بين قوات من الوحدات الخاصه اليمنيه و
سلاحين في اللجان الشعبيه الجنوبيه في عدن
واقع يراقبه الخارج وتحديدا واشنطن التي
تعتبر اليمن منذ سنوات ساحه حرب لها مع
القاعده من الهند اكد الرئيس الامريكي
باراك اوباما عدم تعليق عمليات بلاده ضد
القاعده في اليمن رغم سيطره الحوثيين
المدعومين من ايران على مقاليد السلطه
الاسبوع الماضي لا داعي لقلق واشنطن فيما
يبدو من الوضع الجديد في اليمن فقبل يومين
قال المتحدث باسم البيت الابيض جوش
انه ليس واضحا ما اذا كانت ايران تسيطر
على الحوثيين فضلا عما نقلته مصادر صحفيه
عن مايكل فيكرز مساعد وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لشؤون الاستخبارات مما يشير
لعلاقات استخباراتيه خلال الاشهر الماضيه
بين بلاده والحوثيين في اطار ما يسمى
مكافحه
الارهاب معنا في هذه الحلقه من صنعاء محمد
العماد الخبير في شؤون جماعه انصار الله
الحوثييين احمد الزرقى الك والمحلل
والمحلل السياسي معنا ايضا من صنعاء اما
ضيفنا من تعز فهو احمد المقرمي القيادي في
التجمع اليمني للاصلاح اهلا بضيوفنا
الثلاثه نبدا بالسيد احمد المقرمي في
تعز هذه الاحتجاجات الغاضبه ضد جماعه
انصار الله الى اين يمكن ان
تصل سيد احمد مكرمي لا يسمعني اذا انقل
هذا السؤال الى السيد احمد الزرقا الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي برايك الى اين يمكن ان
تصل هذه الاحتجاجات الغاضبه ضد جماعه
انصار
الله هذه الاحتجاجات تمثل هي البدايه
الاولى لفعل شعبي وحراك شعبي ضاغط على
جماعه الحوثيين وعلى التحركات او تصرفات
الميليشيات المسلحه التي ربما انتهكت
الحياه السياسيه واسهمت في تعطيل المسار
السياسي في اليمن وهي اليوم
الشبهه ببدايات 2000 ثوره 11 فبراير في
2011 بنفس السيناريو يسير كان هناك مجموعه
تحركات شبابيات يقمعها النظام واليوم نفس
الحركه يقوم شباب الجامعه بالتحرك وتتصدى
لهم جماعه الحوثي بال بالعنف وبالضرب و
بالاعتداء عليهم وبالتالي ربما النتيجه هي
مقاربه هذه الجماعه تضيق ذرعا
بال بالصوت الرافض لتحركاتها وتحركات
ميليشياتها رغم انها تحركات سلميه لم تكن
تحركات مسلحه
اليوم ما يحدث انه الحوثيين حتى تنكروا
لثوره لشباب الثوره شباب الجامعات الذين
اسهموا في 2011 في رفع الظلم عن جماعه
الحوثي وايصالهم الى الحياه السياسيه ما
يحدث اليوم هو تصرف ارعن استقواء بالسلاح
بالقوه استقوى ايضا بالميليشيات ضد الشباب
السلمين لكن هذه تكشف ان الاصوات الشابه
واصوات الشباب وشباب الجامعات هي اصوات
حقيقيه بعيده عن الاصوات الحزبيه ومطالبها
واضح وسلميه وبالتالي على جماعه الحوثي
ربما جماعه الحوثي لم تعتد هذا النوع من
السلوك هي اعتادت ان تضع شروطها على
الاحزاب السياسيه وعلى النظام السياسي
وعلى الرئيس هادي ونظامه وهم يستجيبوا لكن
اليوم ربما الرفض ياتي من المجتمع ويؤكد
ان هناك حركه اتساع ان حركه الرفض تتسع
يوما بعد يوم ليست فقط في صنعاء انما في
صنعاء وغيرها من المحافظات وهذا دليل على
ان الحوثي ليس وحده قادرا على اداره
الاوضاع وليس وليست ميليشياته قادره على
ان تطبق على حريه التعبير في اليمن هناك
اليوم
يعني بعد اذنك بعد اذنك لو اسال
السيد السيد محمد العماد عما اذا كان يبدو
غريبا ان جماعه انصار الله لم يكتفوا بان
تحولوا الى سلطه امر واقع تحولوا الان الى
سلطه قمعيه لجماهير تنزل الى الشارع الا
يبدو هذا مشهدا
غريبا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم بدايه اشكرك سيدي
العزيز واشكر ضيوفك فيما يخص الحاصل في
اليمن او ما يخرج من مسيرات اولا يجب ان
نفرق في بثوره 2011 والذي افتخر بانني كنت
احد اعضاء اللجنه التنظيم حينها وان افرق
بالخروج اليوم كانت ثوره 2011 ثوره شبابيه
خارجه من اراده شعبيه من قمع كان حاصل من
نظام لكل القوى السياسيه
ما يحصل الان هم من خرج الان هم مج هم
جناح شبابي من مكونات اللقاء المشترك
الاصلاح وال والناصري والاشتراكي وما الى
ذلك ولهذا عندما عندما احاول ان اجعل هناك
ثوره شعبيه لا هناك هناك تحرك من مكونات
من اجل الضغط في
عدم المضي قدما بالاتفاقيات الذي تم على
اساس اتفاق السلم والشراكه مخرجات الحوار
الوطني ولهذا جعلوا من القوى السياسيه
القوى السياسيه في اللقاء المشترك جعلت من
الشباب ادوات كما جعلت منها في 2011 للاسف
الكبير ولهذا يجب ان ان نسمي الاشياء
بمسمياتها وانا وان لا نذهب الى ثوره كثور
2011 نعم يعني حتى لو سمينا سيد محمد
العماد الاشياء باسمائها لنفترض ان هؤلاء
فعلا جناح شبابي من من سيارات محدده
ونزلوا الى الشارع للاحتجاج على هيمنه
جماعه انصار الله على المدن وعلى دواليب
الدوله اليس من حقهم التعبير عن وجهه
النظر هذه حتى وان كانت فقط
للاحتجاج سيدي العزيز في مساله التعبير
يجب ان نعلم بان الكل له حق التعبير ولكن
اذا كان اصحاب الاحياء الذي هم من قاموا
من قاموا ولم يجمعهم ومن رفضوا ان يكونوا
في تلك الشوارع لانهم ح لانهم لا ظوا بان
هؤلاء مجرد ادوات لاحزاب هذا شيء فيما يخص
مساله الحريه حريه التعبير نحن نعلم بان
احنا في في مرحله صعبه جدا مرحله القاعده
السيارات المفخخه العبوات الناسفه يجب ان
تعلم تلك القوه بان بانه لا تستطيع بان
تحول تعمل مجزره وتحمل انصار الله ولهذا
يجب على القوى السياسيه بان
تدرك الوقت الحساس الذي تمر به اليمن وان
وانا يجعلوا في ابتزاز سياسي لقوه من
القوى السياسيه تحت تحت ذريعه الدماء دماء
الشباب ونطمن الجميع لا يوجد لو كان هناك
قمع حقيقي لراي كل القنوات تنشر مباشر
راينا الغازات السامه هناك
القوه امن امن محافظه صنعاء لم لم يجمعهم
هو امنهم اذا كان في احتك احتكك كان مع
المواطنين و مع جنا عسكري نعم اسمح لي هنا
قبل ان اسال السيد احمد المقرمي هنا
للتوضيح كل وكال
الانباء اوردت بان هذه المظاهرات جوبهت
بالقمع تم اعتقال صحفيين تم الاعتداء على
صحفيين حتى ان احد الصحفيين الذين اعتقلوا
وهو من من وكاله رويترز يقول ان جماعه
الحوثيين واسمه محمد السياغي مصور مع
رويترز يقول جماعه الحوثي تصرفوا معنا
بجنون تصرفوا ضد المتظاهرين بجنون هذا
تعبير وانا انقل الكلام اسمح لي اسال
السيد احمد المقرمي القيادي في التجمع
اليمني للاصلاح احد الشباب الذين شاركوا
في مظاهرات اليوم يقول نحن نشارك في هذه
المظاهرات لاستعاده الدوله نطالب باستعاده
الدوله هل ترون ان هذه
هي الاهداف الحقيقيه لهذه التحركات سيد
مقرني اولا نحيي صمود شباب الث
اليمنيه في جامعه صنعاء من الطلاب
والطالبات الذين واجهوا اله القمع التي
مازالت تعمل ضدهم والتي
راح اعتقل فيها اكثر من 15 طالب وطالبه
وتعرضوا فيها لكلمات نابيه وكلمات لا تليق
اضافه الى اثاره النعرات معينه اثناء
توجيههم او توجيه جماعه الحوثي الخطاب
لهؤلاء الطلاب او تلك الطالبات وكان من
عار ان يتعرض الصرح العلمي الاكاديمي
جامعه صنعاء الى مثل هذه التصرفات الرعناء
ومن الخطا ان يقول ضيفك ان الشعب اليمني
يقزم في خروجه من خلال هؤلاء الشباب الى
انها ال ان هؤلاء الذين خرجوا انما يمثلون
الاصلاح او الناصري او المشترك بشكل عام
وانما هذه اراده الشعب هي التي خرجت الامر
الثاني لا نريد من احد ان يتوسل دعم مواقف
دول اخرى من خلال القاعده التي تعلق شماعه
اليوم لجلد الشعب اليمني ولقم
وارهاب الامر الاهم اليوم هو ان هؤلاء
الشباب وكل الذين خرجوا في جميع المحافظات
انما خرجوا من اجل ان يستعيدوا دوله
مختطفه ومن اجل ان يستعيدوا وطنا تريد بعض
جماعات التخلف اسمح لي بهذه العباره بعض
هذه الجماعات ان تصادر اراده ثوره واراده
شعب واراده 50 سنه من البناء ومن محاوله
رقي بهذا الشعب هذه الدوله التي تختطف
اليوم انما اختطفتها اساليب همجيه كما قال
بعض الاخوه في اللقاء المشترك او في بعض
الاحزاب اليوم هذا الاسلوب الذي يتم
التعامل معه سواء كان مع الصرح العلمي في
جامعه صنعاء او مع الشباب او مع عامه
الناس في في الشارع الذي انتفض من في كل
المحافظات انما خرج هذا معبرا عن ان هذا
الاسلوب الذي يتم اتخاذه اليوم او الذي
يتم ممارسته من قبل هذه الجماعات او
الميليشيات انما من اجل ان ينقذوا هذه
الدوله وهذا الوطن من تغول مثل هذه
الميليشيات التي ستعمل على تشديه الوطن
وعلى تمزيقه وعلى تمزيق النسيج الاجتماعي
من خلال تلك الثقافه التي يحاولون نشرها خ
تلك الكلمات او البارات الت يعني اسمح لي
هذا الاسلوب في التظاهر تعتقد انه الان في
هذه المرحله هو الاسلوب الانجع لاستعاده
الاوضاع الطبيعيه واستعاده الدوله
المختطفه كما تقول
انت هناك محور شبابي وهناك محور سياسي حيث
ما عجز او سدت القنوات
واغلقت المنافذ امام الحوار الذي كان
ينبغي ان يتعاطى معه جميع الاطراف
بمسؤوليه وطنيه وان يسعى الجميع للخروج
باليمن من هذا النفق المظلم ومن هذا النفق
السيء ومن هذا الوضع البائس لكن الاخوه في
جماعه
الحوثي سدوا جميع المنافذ للحوار فكان
لابد لهؤلاء الذين للشباب كافه بل لعامه
الشعب اليمني ان يخرج غير عابئ بهذه
التوازنات السياسيه ولا الحسابات السياسيه
والشارع اليوم يتحرك ليس بداء من هذا
الحزب او ذاك وانما هو نوع من التعاطي
والتفاعل مع طموحات هذا الشعب الذي خرج في
ثوره
فبراير بعد اذنك نحن من بدايه نحن بعد
اذنك سيد بعد اذنك سيد مقرم نحن منذ
البدايه نتحدث عن هذه الاحتجاجات ونتحدث
عنها ضمن السياق الوطني الداخلي نريد ان
نعرف بعد الفاصل الى اي مدى المجتمع
الدولي سواء دول الجوار او الامم المتحده
او او الولايات المتحده قادره على ان تؤثر
في الوضع الحالي في اليمن بهدف استعاده
الاوضاع الطبيعيه فيه لنا عوده بعد فاصل
نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها تطورات الوضع
السياسي والميداني في اليمن سيد احمد
الزرقا اذا تابعنا ردود الفعل العربيه
والدوليه عما يجري في اليمن لا تبدو
المؤشرات مشجعه لا المبعوث الدولي جمال بن
عمر قال كلاما واضحا وفيه ادانه لما يجري
ولا الولايات المتحده تبدو مكترث بما يجري
في اليمن ولا دول الجوار تبدو منشغله ب
ملفات عديده اخرى هل تعتقد بان هذا الوضع
يسمح بتدخل سياسي ما ودبلوماسي في
اليمن الا ان اليمن كان خلال الثلاث سنوات
الماضيه هو في عهده المجتمع الدولي وفي
عهده جمال بن عمر والدول العشره الراعيه
للمبادره الخليجيه وباعتقادي انهم لم
يكونوا عند قدر المسؤوليه لم ينجحوا في
اداره هذا الملف وربما تقارير جمال بن عمر
تكشف يعني حجم التواطؤ الذي كان فيه
يتواطأ عن طريق ربما الضغط عن بواسطه
ايران التي لديها خطوط واضحه او سواء عبر
وسيط عماني الذي كان الوسيط العماني او
عبر ايران مباشره او عبر حزب الله
الجماعات الاخرى التي لديها صلات واضحه
بجماعه الحوثيين لكن بقيه الاطراف الدوليه
ربما باعتقاد دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
منشغله بملفاتها الاخرى بصراعات اخرى
بتطبيع الاوضاع الداخليه بين تلك الدول
وبالتالي اليمن بحاجه الى ربما الجماعه
هذهه لن تتوقف الا اذا وجهت او جوبهت ب رد
فعل شعبي شامل وليس رد فعل خارجي ربما ما
ما يحدث الان من تحركات داخليه هي الطريقه
الانجع لمواجهه الحوثيين خاصه انها ستكون
طريقه سلميه عن طريق احتجاجات شعبيه وليس
لها علاقه بالعنف وليس لها علاقه لان
العنف هو الميدان الوحيد الذي تبرع فييه
هذه الجماعه وبالتالي الاطار السلمي او
الحل التحرك السلمي هو ما يحرج هذه
الجماعه ويجعلها تنكشف وتنكشف ادعاءات
التي تحدثت عنها خلال الفتره الماضيه
بالدعاء السلميه وال المظلوميه والى اخره
اما المجتمع الدولي وجمال بن عمر باعتقادي
ان المرحله تجاوزتهم بشكل كبير جدا جمال
بن عمر منذ يومن في صنعاء ولم نسمع له اي
خبر ولم نسمع له اي تحرك بالعكس منذ ان
جاءت تعقدت الازمه اليمنيه وزادت وتوترت
كثيرا واستقال الرئيس هذه واستقاله
الحكومه ولم نسمع رد فعل ما زال يتحدث عن
ضروره التزام الجميع باتفاق السلم
والشراكه وهو السلم الذي دهسته دهسه
الحوثيون
بالدبابات
و حلقات التحرك الحالي لانه عندما نتابع
وهنا اسال السيد محمد العماد يعني حتى
عندما الغريب يعني هناك ظاهره غريبه سيد
العماد ا حتى الولايات المتحده التي هي في
شعارات جماعه انصار الله الموت لامريكا
الموت لاسرائيل الى اخره نراها غير غير
عابئ كثيرا بسيطره الحوثيين على دواليب
الدوله حتى الرئيس اوباما لم يبدي قلقا
تجاه هذا الموضوع هو تحدث فقط عن مجابهه
الارهاب الا تب تبدو هذه مؤشرات يعني
ملفته للانتباه
برايكم سيدي العزيز فقط تعجيب لما طرحه
الاخ من تعز فيما يخص الاهداف الحقيقيه
الاهداف الحقيقيه وراء هذه المسيرات هي
اهداف اخوانيه في اقصاء طرف الطرف الذي
نصت عليه مبادر المخرجات الحوار وهو
الحراك الجنوبي وانصار الله في الشراكه
الحقيقه لا نزايد ولا نحاول ان نبتعد عن
المحور الحقيقي اما اما المسيرات التي
تخرج هو امس بانت حقيقتها في فيما يخص
الشعارات الطائفيه المحرضه لزيد ولهذا هذه
مسيره اريد ان اوضح فقط للمشاهد هذه مسيرت
اخوانيه
طائفيه بسبقه للاسف ناصريه اشتراكيه هي ت
هي عاشت او تعايشت مع المناصب او الفه
الذي ياتي من جناح الاخوان المسلمين من
بعد
ثوره لا التوضيح وصل التوضيح وصل الله
يخليك خلينا خلينا في محور التحركات
الدوليه التوضيح التوضيح التوضيح الذي
قدمته التوضيح الذي قدمته وصل اعطيني جواب
على ما طرحته من
فضلك في ساتكلم ساتكلم عن الج اخلص ذلك
فقط بان الدوله الي الذي خافوا عليه هي
دوله الاخوان ودوله القوى التقليديه اما
ما يخص الدوله الحديثه هي نصت على مخرجات
الحو فيما يخص المجتمع الدولي او
التصريحات الامريكيه او الاوروبيه فليعلم
الجميع بان من حاول الاستئثار على الثورات
في 2011 سقط لانه كان يراهن على المجتمع
بين قوسين الامريكي الاخوه راهنوا على
المجتمع الامريكي في مصر وسقطوا لان من
يراهن على الخارج سيسقط الاصوات النشاز
الذي الان في اليمن هي ستسقط لان الشارع
لو كان الشارع بيدهم لخرجوا مثل ما خرجت
المسيرات بالمئات الالاف في صنعاء خرجت في
صعده خرجت في عمران اما من يحول ا يحول ان
يستب
ث بعد اذنك سيد عماد انا توقفت عند شيء
ملفت للانتباه انتم جماعه تق في شعارها
على كل العربات وفي كل المناسبات الموت
لامريكا الموت لاسرائيل الى اخره الولايات
المتحده في كل تصريحاتها لم تبدي قلقا من
ان الدوله اصبحت في يد الحوثيين لم تبدي
امتعاضا لذلك ولا ادانه لذلك اوباما يتحدث
في الهند عن ان محاربه الارهاب في اليمن
متواصله لم يبدي اي قلق الا يب حتى اعضاء
السفاره الامريكيه في
اليمن خفضوا تدريجيا لكنهم لم يغلقوا
سفارتهم بمعنى الولايات المتحده لا تشعر
لا بالخوف ولا بالتهديد من جماعه الحوثي
انا سؤالي ان كان ذلك يبدو غريبا لانه
بالنسبه للموقف الامريكي مما يجري في
اليمن يبدو غريب
عجيب لا باعتقادي ليس غريب وليس عجيب
والسبب لشيء واحد بان من كان يخوف
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ويجعل الانصار
الله شماعه باسم ايران لقد رحلوا لقد
رحلوا من المشهد السياسي وما بقي الا بعض
الاصوات المرتزقه من خارج تحت هذا الهلال
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تدرك ادراكا
كاملا بان الشعار الموت الامريكي هو شعار
سياسي لسياده وامن اليمن في في اي تدخل
وليس فقط في التدخل الامريكي ولهذا
الولايات المتحده لم تلاحظ على ارض الواقع
بانه تم اختطاف جندي امريكي لم جندي
امريكي من يحمون على على السفاره وقامت
مسيره سلميه وستصل الدوله دوله الشراكه
الحقيقه الى رحيل هذا المارز الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لاحظت خلال الاربعه
الاشهر الماضيه ب لم تحدث مواجهات مع معها
لماذا لماذا نحاول كمكونات يمنيه بان نستع
طف الخارج والبند السابع لضرب اليمن اذا
انت تؤكد بشكل غير مباشر بانكم لا تمثلون
اي خطر على الولايات المتحده ولستم عنصر
ازعاج لها بدليل الكلام الذي قلته على كل
ليست هذه قضيتنا ولكن اسال في النهايه سيد
احمد المقرمي هل تعتقد بان سواء دول
الجوار او الامم المتحده او اي قوى اخرى
قادره الان على التاثير في المعادله
اليمنيه سيد
مقرب ا نحن في الحقيقه لا نعول كثيرا على
وان كنا بحاجه الى دعم وتدخل الاشقاء
والاصدقاء
ولكن التعويل هو على الشارع اليمني الذي
هب من جديد ليس مختزلا في حزب معين وانما
كشعب كامل الذي يحاول ان يسطح الموضوع
ويقول ان هناك حزبا معينا هو من ندفع بهذه
الجموع وهذه الجماهير هذه عباره عن نوع من
الهروب الى من نوع من الهروب
الذي من الهروب الذي مثله الشارع اليمني
من خلال الهبه الشعبيه الواضحه ضد مثل هذه
التصرفات وبالتالي فاننا ننتظر من المجتمع
الدولي ان يكون له موقفا من هذه الاسلحه
التي اتسح العاصمه واسقطت عاصمه واعتدت
على رمز السياده في الوطن وهو دار الرئاسه
يعني لا تعول يعني عفوا عفوا سيد مخرمه
يعني لا تعول على اجتماعات السيد بن عمر
مع كل هذه الاطراف لاستعاده
الوضع نحن نظل نظل متفائلين ولكن ما سبق
من معطيات لم نجد ما يقول كلمه واحده عن
هذه ميليشيات التي اسقطت عاصمه والتي
اختطفت دوله
والتي اختطفت وزارات وما زال بعضهم حتى
اليوم تحت الحصار هل هذه هي مخرجات الحوار
التي يتحدث عنها هؤلاء الاخوه ام ان هذه
هي
نتيجه السلم والشراكه التي كان يفترض انها
تطبق من يوم من يوم التوقيع عليها ثم تهرب
هؤلاء الاخوه من تنفيذها هذه الامور نريد
من المجتمع الدولي ان يكون
صادقا وشاهدا حقيقيا في ممارسه في النظر
من يعرقل مثل هذه المخرجات ومثل هذه
الاتفاقات بمسؤوليه دوليه كما اننا نحب ان
يكون هنا في اليمن مسؤوليه وطنيه شكرا لك
سييد احمد المقرمي القيادي في التجمع
اليمني للاصلاح كنت معنا من تعز شكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من صنعاء محمد العماد الخبير في
شؤون جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين واحمد
الزرقا الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي في امان الله
[موسيقى]